the jurogan experience if you look at
that last card that we did
i think i had three of the biggest
fights of any ufc card i did the cub
swanson fight
what i did fight that one it was holy
[ __ ] i get about a 20-minute break and
then i do
kevin holland versus jacare and then i
finished my night
with tony ferguson and oliveira
that was crazy too so it's like man
three crazy [ __ ] crazy fights so
yeah god that's a great card that kevin
holland ko was bananas i think i've done
and you know we don't have anything to
do with the assignments the athletic
commission gives us
our fights i've done kevin holland's
like the last four fights
and you know i tell folks i got the
greatest seat in the world sitting there
in the octagon with these you know men
and women who go in there and do that
stuff but
i fortunately have with great mentors
and guidance and opportunities for the
ufc and so many organizations
have gotten some of the biggest and best
fights in the world i'm very high on
kevin holland
he's something special he's good he's
got crazy power and it's weird
like to knock out jacare off your back
with a punch
like what and we sit there and you know
you look at both fighters and see what's
happening and i go it went down to the
ground
and you have to know your fighters to
know where their expertise is going to
happen well he's a travis luther
trained uh jiu jitsu practitioner and
travis luter
one of the best american jiu jitsu
practitioners really ever
he travis luther you know it's a it
comes from a different era
but back in his day like the guys that i
know that trained with him
were like holy [ __ ] is he good and it's
great to see him you know there in the
corner you get to you know sometimes you
chat with these guys and hear all the
stories but he's out of dallas right
yeah when that fight hapworth yeah when
that fight happened
he's on his back and he throws that
first punch and i go okay this is going
to be a transition now look at jockery
and you know if you go back and watch
the fight he's actually rocked yeah when
that first
happened we'll step a little bit closer
and by the time he throws the next three
punches and i'm stepping in to try and
stop
it you know jacare is out and they'll
they'll concentrate on the fighter that
wins
but you know one you don't want a
fighter to come back conscious and take
you down to start to do something
right that does happen and if there's a
language barrier you know so i'm sitting
there telling jacare
the fight's over the fight's over you
know i say stop stop stop so there's no
misunderstanding about what's going on
and i'm holding the
jockery and holding the fence because
he's starting to you know come back
coherent again
right and i want him to understand that
he's been knocked out and you know he's
like no no i'm good i'm good
i'm going nah man you got knocked out
you've been out for you know a minute or
two
isn't that crazy everybody eventually
starts to come back they all think
they're fine like people think
that fighters like they're trying to
cheat or something like that
like you don't understand what it's like
and you get knocked out and especially
fighters when they come back
they think they're in the fight exactly
like they'll try to take a referee down
they're holding on to pants legs
they don't even think that it's a pants
leg and then eventually they go why is
this
i'm these are black pants it's always
what is this what happened yeah what
happened they always say what happened
yeah or they they get the bright light
of the you know the doctors shining the
flashlight in our eyes
what happened yeah one thing we tried to
transition doing
you know i've had some fighters get
really hurt really bad
we normally keep everybody out of the
octagon but one thing we're doing
is we're allowing a coach to come in
with the doctor with the inspectors with
myself
and give them a familiar voice you know
you get knocked out you come back and
here's mark telling you now the fight's
over you may not recognize but if your
coach is there in the corner
saying hey such and such you got knocked
out calm down it's fine this is coach
touch and such i'm here
we're finding that's calming a fighter
down just a little bit obviously medical
protocols and safety we got to do all
that but
i like doing that i like asking one of
the coaches to come in stand off to my
side and kind of give them a familiar
voice
when oliveira had tony ferguson in that
arm bar
and he had his arm completely
hyper-extended it looked like his arm
was breaking
like what was your thought there because
some guys have stopped fights when a guy
has a
fully locked out arm bar and it's very
controversial like some people think you
should just let it keep going
other people think like that one of the
best examples was
herb dean with tim sylvia versus frank
muir that went through my mind
yeah and see what a lot of people didn't
understand at first is herb is looking
directly at his arm
and he heard it too heard it he heard
the crack yeah now he caught a lot of
flack for that
he only did for a couple seconds once i
got in the octagon and i explained it
and i explained it to the audience
because people were booing like crazy
because the fight was stopped
tim tilly's like what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] meanwhile his arm was
she had that adrenaline going too well
his arm was gone yeah
i mean it was and then i explained it on
tv and then when i got into the octagon
and i said i want you to look at
something watch this watch this and then
you hear everybody go
oh when you see his forearm bend in half
and then everybody's like oh so that
level
with the choke i'll tell guys in the
rule meeting in the back i'm not going
to stop unless you go out
you could have someone in a fully
compromised position
you know who was it the kiessa fight yes
you know he was
fully compromised but how good could it
be how how long can he hold it can he
turn his chin to the side and get out
yeah you got to let him go out you got
to let him go outside
kevin lee has a nasty rear naked choke
and he had kiosa
fully locked even in that position you
got to let him go so i tell guys
and we learn as we progress watching
fights you know we talk
daily weekly about stuff that we got to
do so i tell them in the back and rules
mini
for a choke at this level i'm not going
to stop it unless the fighter goes out
good
if it's any kind of other submission i
got to see a dislocation separation or
it has to break
or if you scream and there's a
difference between a scream and a you
know a grunt to get out of something if
you scream it's a verbal submission and
we're going to stop
that's a weird one right now verbal
submission thing is weird
man that was you could saw his leg off
with a rusty [ __ ] axe that was beyond
human
because he will not tap when when
charles transitioned from across the
chest to under the under arm
tony grunted yeah and he bare through it
and look at that the hyper extension i i
don't know what happened to his elbow
you can see my foot there look how close
i am so i'm doing two things one i'm
looking for
a dislocation separation or break but
i'm also
listening to see if it's going to be
cracked a verbal
you know the cracking arm or verbal
submission he did not he he
man he battled through that and there's
we got to be conscious of the time
so the 10 second clapper had already
gone off so i'm counting down in my head
and the goal is to write when that horn
goes off
you'll see when we stop a submission
from that we go right to the pressure
point
push back the opposite way and take off
the
the pivot point and it's under arm to
stop it because some guys are going to
try to hold it for an extra second
right after the bill goes off right as
that stops i'm pushing on it and
stopping it
also verbally telling the guy to stop
because you don't want any extra damage
after the bill you remember
who samara pajar is yes yeah yeah so
we saw and i think he'd fight jake
shields or something like that what's
that
loud noise all of a sudden that thing
oh great um i think when he fought jake
shields you know there was some extra
curricular
that was with um kimura and that was in
uh the pfl right yeah he held on to a
kimura
tap jake but then held it long and then
afterwards there was a brawl inside the
octagon but
yeah and i think i'd referee the fight
right before that and you know it's our
responsibility as a referee to
know your fighter you gotta you know we
do you i what i do is i look at the
entire card and i'll go back and try to
look at their fight so whatever i get
assigned and i don't know what i get
assigned until i get there
to know if anyone has any tendencies you
know are they great on the stand up are
they great on the ground
that they have a tendency to foul
because we got some guys that like to
fight with their fingers extended a lot
and i put that into my rules meeting of
you know watch fingers
just what is going to be fingers
straight to the sky or make a fist or
someone has a propensity to follow a lot
that may be something i'm going to watch
out for now when you see something like
that
if you saw the arm break you would have
stopped it i would have stopped did you
have to but
look how bad it looks yeah it's so crazy
how
hyper extended that thing is yeah now
you got some folks that are
super double it and they will tell you
ahead of time pay them
a flexibility i'm double jointed do you
remember uh hoiler gracie versus
sakaraba
um it was that with the he had him in a
kimura as well
and he got his arm like way wrapped up
behind his back but hoiler has
crazy joint flexibility like it's really
nuts like and he was like i'm fine i'm
fine they stopped the fight and he was
furious
because his arm was like sakurabo is a
catch wrestling guy you know so
he's got a lot of those like old school
double wrist lock techniques that are
really brutal in the joints and he's
got his arm like deep up high on his
back and he's twisting it
but whaler was like i'm fine i'm not
tapping yeah and he won't tap
which is crazy and it depends on the
level so like can we do tough enough to
amateur fight steer
uh yeah yeah if it keeps going you can
see that's only the beginning of it
um it got a lot worse if you say hoiler
versus
no that is that's the beginning of it
yeah like at the amateur level
somebody could be in a choke and if it's
compromised we may stop the fight or if
they get stuck in the arm bar or
something don't demonstrate the
capability right
right in the amateurs yeah so this is
hoist choice
that's hoist this is a different guy
spoiler is much smaller that's the
problem with sakuraba
sakuraba is a big guy and a hoiler is
fairly small spoilers like i mean he
might be like 160
maybe catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience